what do you expect in terms of units
sold and why do you expect that to load
corry hello Paul thank you for having me
so we are pretty optimistic on the
opportunity at about 15.4 million
shipped this year and we think that
supply will be fairly well matched to
demand you'll see an initial rush of
folks likes the ones we've seen who
turning and hollering in the auditorium
the dockyard loyalists the fanboys
they'll camp out outside the apple
stores maybe in igloos here in Boston
but you'll get maybe three to four
million in the first month that way by
our estimation you'll see steady uptake
through the year and seasonally you'll
see a pretty pretty good holiday you
know build up towards the end the reason
that we're so optimistic and believe
that apple will gitam eyes the space is
you know they bring the design pedigree
and they bring the designer curated
options on to the risks of users um you
know I think history has shown it's
pretty unwise to bet against Apple we're
expecting something new in the
smartphone user interface hopefully a
new metaphor for dominating a SmartWatch
like we saw with pinch and zoom
legitimizing the smartphone space the
sidewinder around is maybe a little bit
of tip of the iceberg we'll see where we
go from there Paul whenever someone
tells me it's unwise to bet against
something I'm become very interested in
betting against it three and a half
million seems like a really big number
to me what do you think that's in the
first month is what's close but you know
I've been looking at the numbers
floating around and you know they're the
numbers are uniformly surprisingly large
you know I mean with this ticking at the
exception of you know the outright
skeptics you see numbers from well seven
or eight up to 15 million first year
unit sales I mean these are colossal
numbers when you consider you know
Android SmartWatch unit sales you know
what are we sitting at now but have we
broached a million yana breached a
million i don't think we have so you
know these are these are really big
numbers and so you know what the bet is
implicitly isn't just Apple it's a bet
that the mistake everybody made in the
past was they didn't make it an
accessory to their iPhone because really
that's what the Apple watch is in the
sense right it requires the smartphone
all the time but require
is this kind of presence of the
smartphone so it's really an apple you
know I phone accessory and so the bat is
that Apple's got that right and that
people want this accessory on their risk
to their iphone that's a pretty big bad
and you know the early numbers suggests
that you know consumer uptake hasn't
been that great and anyone else out
there so you know I'm still skeptical I
don't think those numbers are going to
happen but you know kudos Apple if they
can pull it off but that's really what
you're betting on is this accessory
argument cliff when you look at the
SmartWatch business you know Paul made
the case earlier and really briefly
cliff you know there are competitors
garments got a great device for athletes
Fitbit and jawbone up our great device
for the for the casual Walker does this
do everything a little bit watch is it
really going to grow the market I think
it read Cory if you looked at what
happened in the mobile world congress in
barcelona we saw that fashion and
convenience and trying to make a watch
that looks good trumped functionality i
think we're going to see a blend of both
here so you know what does apple have up
its sleeve it won't be a newton it's not
in their contemporary DNA to introduce
substandard experiences i think history
will tell us even in the cook era that
we won't see it launched without
something jaw-dropping with battery life
required they have the uncanny ability
to think three-dimensionally it'll have
a new UI will see some really impressive
launch partners so far the applications
tend to have their counterparts in the
Bologna co system in the enterprise
system will see something new here to
cliff Roscoe